Добрий день Мене звуть Іван Терещенко я
прес-секретар молодіжної ради сам
студент національного університету
черніівська політехніка я навчаюся на
соціального працівника і в майбутньому
планую займатися допомогою людям саме в
цій сфері Спочатку повномасштабного
вторнення я займаюся волонтерством і це
справді мене надихає надихає саме з того
дня коли я роздавав гуманітарку родині
яка приїхала до нас просто нізчим до
нашого міста ВПО вони були я побачив очі
їхніх двох доньок які були настільки
щирі настільки вдячні за ту допомогу що
з того дня я заряджений цією ідею
допомагати людям і досі
Допомагаю я справді дуже радай що Серед
моїх однолітків стільки людей що роблять
стільки всього хорошого для інших їх
справді можна назвати покоління
[музика]
Перемоги